FLORIAN LOITSCH: So
hi, my name is Florian.
And I'm working also in
the office in Denmark,
and I'm going to present
asynchronous programming
in Dart.
So a small outline-- I will
start with an introduction,
compare the asynchronous and
synchronous programming model,
and remind you of how the
asynchronous primitives work
in Dart.
I will then spend a
little bit of time
on this new, cool feature
they've introduced in 1.9,
Async/Await, talk-- I have
a few slides on debugging--
and then finish with a summary.
So basically an introduction
of asynchronous programming
versus synchronous programming
can be reduced to two words,
basically wait or yield, so
basically wait or don't wait.
And I will give a small example
of what I mean with that.
Let's say, you
have a web server.
And you get a request in.
So if you're in a parallel
synchronous environment, what
you can do is, you
spawn off a thread.
Then you're handed a response.
And at some point, when
you're done, you have a reply.
And your return that response.
Now, if you get a
second request in,
you just do the
same thing again.
You spawn off a thread.
You handle the request.
And then, at some point,
you have a response.
And you do that for all
the requests that come in.
And if you do that, you have
a nice parallel execution.
You have, in this
case, five threads.
And you just run them.
It looks kind of
nice, busy, great.
The problem with it is,
clearly, in the moment,
you have multi-threading.
So parallel execution,
you have race conditions.
That's a classic problem.
But it also is
that, it can also be
the threads are
expensive, especially
if you use system threads.
You only have a
limited number of them,
and it costs to put
them up and run them.
And it's also an
inefficient use of threads.
And the reason for that
is that, let's say, we
have this thread running here.
It looks very busy.
It looks like it's
doing a lot of things.
But really, what's happening
most of the time in reality
is that you have system calls.
And during the
system calls, you're
just waiting for the system.
You're actually
not doing anything.
And in the end, your there is
just waiting for the system
most of the time.
So the asynchronous
program modeling return
basically says, don't
wait, especially
for these systems calls.
We will call you back.
So the system will
call you back.
So if you go back to
these parallel tasks that
are running in multiple threads,
the green and the blue ones
here, in the parallel
synchronous model,
you just had to threads.
And they were waiting.
Whereas, in the asynchronous
model, you're just one thread.
And you run the same
tasks on the same thread.
And you just basically, when
you're waiting for the system,
you continue running another
task on the same thread.
So even though, as you can
see, it's not as fast and true,
because well, you sometimes
could run two things
at the same time.
But the thread makes
you basically wait
for the other one to finish.
In total, for one,
given that we only
use one thread,
instead of two, we
don't lose much time for that.
The other thing that's
important to note
is that there's a typically
asynchronous pattern,
in the sense that when
you ask for something
that takes a long
time-- so here,
it's called doSomethingSlow.
You give that
function a callback.
So that when it's done,
it can call you back.
And then, more importantly,
you go back to the event loop.
So instead of waiting
for the thing to return,
you just finish all your things.
You return from Main.
And then, only at some
point, the event loop
will come back and call you.
So this has a few properties.
For one, it's a better
use of the thread.
As I said, you use fewer threads
for the same number of tasks.
It's a cooperative model.
So on the same
threads, you're not
going to have race conditions
if you do not yield.
I mean, obviously,
once you yield,
you let others do something
on your static variables.
It's callback based.
And there must be an event loop.
And the interesting
part about the callback
based and the event
loop is that this
is something that fits very
well in UI-driven, event-driven
programs.
So there's a nice fit of
asynchronous programming
and event-driven,
UI-driven programs.
And that also means that
programs are more reactive.
If you have UI on
one thread and you do
asynchronous programming
on the same thread.
Well, because you do
not wait and you do not
block your threads,
your program actually
can still do UI, while you
are waiting for the system
and so on.
So now this was the
small synchronous
versus asynchronous programming.
How does it work in Dart?
From the beginning on, when
we designed the [INAUDIBLE]--
and when we designed Dart, we
had asynchronous programming
in mind.
And there's a nice
library, dart colon async,
has also lots of primitives.
And I will show at least a few
[INAUDIBLE] in the next slides.
And we also use these
asynchronous primitives
all over the place.
So dart io, dart convert,
html, and isolate, all of them
consistently use the
primitives that we have.
Even though, as I said,
HTML, for instance,
is not really an
asynchronous programming,
it's a UI, event-driven
programming model.
But since they
fit so nicely, you
have a consistent model that
fits just all over the place.
So before I talk about the
futures and streams in general,
I want to give
this small picture
of these fundamental
types that you have.
In general, you have
one single value.
That's the single
synchronous case.
Or you return multiple values.
That's the interval case
in synchronous world.
And then in the asynchronous
world, you have a duality.
We have the features for single
values that are not there yet
and streams for multiple values.
So here's the future
from the dot colon async.
So really, a future
just represents
a value that isn't there yet.
And the way to
interact with it, you
have three basic functions
on it-- then, catchError,
and whenComplete.
All of them take a callback,
the callback that you execute
once you have that value.
And all of them also
return a future,
which allows this
nice future chaining
that we have seen earlier and
since beginning, basically,
of Dart.
Here's just a small example
where we create a file.
So we instantiate a new
file, call create on it.
Create, itself,
returns as a future,
so we can do this
nice Dart chaining.
We do that Dart then.
We add the callback.
We also get a future
back, which allows us
Dart catchError on it,
which then-- depending on
if we were able to create the
file or not-- prints created
or couldn't create.
Basic things-- we have had
that in Dart since 1.0.
The stream, on the other hand,
it's the asynchronous interval.
So as I said, we have the
duality between single value
and multiple values.
So the stream is the
Asynchronous Iterable.
We have a sequence of values.
And we have operations
to manipulate and filter
those values, just the
same as in iterables.
The main difference is
that iterables are pulled,
and streams are pushed.
And what I mean,
with that is that,
when you have an iterable, in
order to get the next value,
you really have to do something.
You have to say, I
want to move to next.
I want to get the current.
So you are the one in control.
Whereas, if you go for streams,
while here you have the stream
element onClick, you cannot
say, give me the next value.
You can say, yes, once you
have a value, give it to me.
But it's the stream is going
to push the value to you.
That is really the
main difference.
Because if you now
look at the API--
here is the iterable,
for instance.
You have the
Iterator, map, where,
first, forEach, sold
all the things that we
love on these iterables.
If you look at the stream
API, it's almost the same.
We replaced Iterator with
a listen on the callback.
But all the other
functions-- map,
where, first and forEach--
they're all still there.
Clearly, they cannot
return the same values,
because they don't
have those values yet.
So they need to go to
a futures and streams,
in cases where we had
iterables and normal values.
But really the duality between
an iterable and a stream.
And this isn't really nice.
Because when you go now
to this cool feature
that we introduced
recently, Async/Await,
the whole concepts
really emerge even more.
And basically, when we
introduced Async/Await,
the main purpose
behind Async/Await
is to make it nice
and easy to program
in asynchronous programs.
And for that, the main
point is improve the syntax.
We want to make it easier to
reason, write, read program
of asynchronous programs.
So let's go back to a small
example of web server in Dart,
so no error handling here.
The way it works in Dart,
we bind an HTTP server
to a socket, locals host here.
And that gives us a future back.
And then we can basically
register our callback.
We can then say, well, once
you have that callback, give me
the server.
I will then listen on all
the requests that come in.
So server is clearly
a stream here.
And then, again, we
pass in the callback,
and we run-- we respond
to these things.
And unfortunately, even
though we love these futures
and streams, if we
had just done this
in any other
callback-based language,
it would have looked
almost the same.
So instead of having the
.then, we would have pushed
the callback directly
to the [INAUDIBLE].
But really, it wouldn't
have changed a lot.
So there are still
too many callbacks.
We like the futures and streams.
They're great, but there are
still too many callbacks.
And what we would like
to have is something
like this imaginary
synchronous zone where we say,
bind this to the server.
And once you're done,
give me the server back.
And then I run through
all the requests,
and I just handle them.
And it just looks very nice,
synchronous, straightforward,
straight-line code.
And Async/Await kind
of tries to get there.
It's Syntactic Sugar.
You start with a
modify on the body,
so that clearly means
it's function local.
And we have explicit points
where we say, well here,
we simulates.
Or we do as if you had
written .then or listen.
So let's go to the web
server that I showed before.
It's the same.
Nothing changed so far.
The first thing we do in
order to use Async/Await
is, as I said, we have
to have a modifier.
So we add the async on the body.
So this is really just
a modifier on the body.
It doesn't change the
signature of the function.
The function still behaves
the same as before.
But once we have
this async modifier,
we can use primitives.
We can use asynchronous
syntax in the body.
So in this case, for
instance, we can say,
we do not want the .then.
on the bind.
We want to say, wait until it's
done, and then we continue.
It looks like it's a
straight synchronous code
we're actuating.
But really this is
the same as before.
We still do it a .then.
It's just Syntactic
Sugar to get there.
And then if we want to
get rid of to the listen,
we also can use await.
And we have a similar syntax as
before in the synchronous code
in await for.
So we take the server
stream and then
run over all the
requests that's come in
and execute to the
request handling.
So this is really--
it's still pretty much
the same code as
before in the sense
that it's still asynchronous.
It's still waiting.
But it looks much, much nicer.
It looks now like the straight
forward synchronous code
that we wanted to have.
So now a few of these
details-- so the first
question, and it's a very
easy question to start with.
What's the static
type of an await?
Actually, it's pretty obvious.
But again, it's the
easy one to start.
If you have a future that
returns a list of string,
for instance.
And you use it with an await.
Well, the static
type of his await
is going to be a generic type of
that future, nothing surprising
here.
The next question,
a little bit more
involved-- what happens if you
wait on a non-future value?
And the way it works in Dart is
that we just make it a future.
So if you do an await on
49, for instance, well,
it becomes an await of a
new Future.value of 499.
The same is true for null.
We just basically wait.
The other thing is--
does work on closures?
Yes.
So even if you use
the arrow braced
or the normal curly
braced closures,
you can just use async there.
It just works the
same way as if you
has a method, just the same.
And finally, and that one is
actually quite interesting,
the body of all
asynchronous functions
is automatically wrapped
in a new Future.microtask.
And that has several
consequences.
So basically, if
you see an async,
you have to
immediately think, this
is as if I saw a new
Future.microtask.
This has several consequences.
One is, you will never have
a synchronous error out
of an async function.
Because you have a
new Future.microtask,
that new Future.microtask will
capture all synchronous errors.
And you will only get
errors back in the future.
The other thing is that it
means that the function yields
immediately when you call it.
So it will go through the
event, before it actually
executes the body.
And then it also gives
us two nice answers
for the questions of what
happens if you return
a future and the return type.
So if you return a future
inside the async body,
well, it will just do
as if you returned it
inside the Future.microtask.
It will wait for the
inner future to complete,
before it completes
the other one.
So that basically
falls out of this.
Similarly, the return
type of an async function
is automatically a future.
So if you see an
async on the body,
it automatically means that
return must be a future.
There's just no way
to get out of that.
Yes, let's talk about
the star versions.
So going back to this table
that we had before-- we
have these four
different data types
that you can return usually or
that are most important ones.
And we always had
the return type
where we can just
return a value.
Now we just added a way to
return a future of a value.
By just adding an
async to the body,
now we can return a
future out of the body.
And in this section, I
will show that we also
have ways to return
a stream on iterable.
So starting with the
iterable, to sync star
is the way to return an
iterable from a function.
So the moment you put a
sync star on the body,
you will return an iterable.
It's the same as for future.
The moment you have it, you
get the return type as fixed.
And sync star is
actually pretty simple.
It allows you to basically
yield inside your body.
And at the places
where you yield,
you push or you put the
value in the iterable.
This is done synchronously.
So basically, once somebody
starts listening or starts
iterating over your
iterable, it will
start executing the function
until it reaches a yield.
And then only the
caller that's called
MoveNext will get the value.
And in this example,
range 3, 6 does
exactly what you expect
it to do-- 3, 4 5 and on.
So what we added with
this sync star keyword
is yield and yield star.
So yield, I just showed,
is basically pushing.
Or it's not really pushing.
It's building the value,
giving the value to the caller.
A yield star pipes through
a completely other iterable.
So if we change
the range function
from before to become
recursive, then we
can yield one value of the
first and then recursively
yield the remaining one.
Yes, that's plus 1.
And we can use yield
star to do that.
And really, it just
takes the iterable
that you got and pipes
it through to the caller.
So that means that
we now have a way
to return an iterable
from a function,
just by adding a
modifier on the body.
And with async star, we also
can do that for Streams.
So once you put an async
star in the function body,
you will return a Stream,
the same as for the futures
and for the iterables.
And we have the
same yield and yield
star as we had for iterables.
But we can also
now use the await.
So in this example, we
have just a function
that returns us the big files
of a list of file names.
We run over these
file names one by one,
open them, stat them, which
is an asynchronous operations.
So it will take the system
a little bit of time
to get that information.
And then we just see if the
file is more than 100,000.
And if it is, we push that
value into the Stream.
So it's a basic,
straightforward loop,
running over all the files.
So since we are in
asynchronous setting,
we have the await
and the await for.
So that works nicely.
And we also now have,
since are a stream,
since we return
multiple values, we
have now yield and yield star.
So this is really
the culmination
of all the modifiers together.
So again, a few things
good to know-- it's
not going to be as much
detail as to the future one.
So one thing you
probably want to know
is that both sync star
and async star functions
are not started before anybody
is listening or iterating
over them.
So it really waits
until somebody actually
needs the values.
The other thing that's
important to know
is that finallies are executed
if a stream is canceled.
This gives you a way
to handle resources.
So you can have a
resource handling,
like opening files,
closing files
in the finallies of a stream.
And then just as an interesting
note, because we discussed it
for a long time,
the yield eventually
returns to an event loop.
So in this example,
for instance,
you have a while (true)
loop, which just yields 499.
And you have different
semantics possible.
One is to say, we just
continue running that loop
and push the value
into some buffer.
And eventually, you just die,
because you run out of memory.
The other one is to
say, at every yield,
we give somebody the
chance to react to it.
Or the third one, which is
the one we haven't taught
is to say, yes,
you can push it in.
But eventually, we know
that it will yield.
It can be immediately.
It can take some time.
It can buffer for some
time for efficiency.
But eventually, you will yield.
So basically what
that means-- you
are allowed to write while
(true), often yields.
And it will work.
So this concludes the
four different sections
of this table.
And we have now ways to return
values, futures, iterables,
and streams, just by adding
modifiers to your function.
And with that, I will
talk a little bit more
about debugging.
As Lars said in
the previous talk,
debugging in asynchronous
programs is really hard.
There is clearly obviously
the interleaved execution.
But more importantly the
stack frames are lost.
And even though I
would have loved
to basically be on
the stage now and say,
yes, we have the great,
great solution here.
And then everything is easy now.
There's actually no
real silver bullet.
We're working on making
things easier and better.
As Lars said, we're trying to
make that much, much better.
But I mean,
interleaved execution,
there's nothing you can do.
That's the whole point of
running asynchronous programs.
You want to alternate
on your thread.
And in stack frames,
it's really hard.
But there are still ways to make
it much, much better right now.
And that's what I want to
talk to in this section.
Here, we have a typical example
of an asynchronous program.
So it's just main calling
gee calling bar calling foo.
And foo is doing some
asynchronous things
and then having an error.
So if we look at the stack
trace of this program,
we will have long stack trace.
But in the end, starting
looking at the stack trace,
there's a lot of things
that we don't care about.
So let's just clean it up
first and look at the stack
once we've removed all the
internal frames that we
actually don't want.
And after the clean-up,
we're already at the point
where we see, well,
There's one stack trace.
Stack one frame, and it's foo.
But it doesn't tell us
where this foo comes from,
why-- basically, it
doesn't help us a all.
What's interesting is,
all these [INAUDIBLE]
noisy frames that you saw
before, the reason for them
are zones.
And these zones, while
they're noisy and annoying,
and we'll try to make that
better in future versions,
and they also help us to have
sophisticated hooks to track
stack traces and to
other fancy stuff.
I could do a full talk in
30 minutes easily on zones.
So I will not go in
a lot of details.
But if you wanted to-- if you
want to check the stack traces
you want to have a
better debugging.
What you will need to do is,
you create a zone description.
Then you fork the zone
with that description.
You intercept all
the synchronous calls
in that zone description again.
You wrap the targets and
start to trace information
on them, so that when you come
back, you can find it again.
And then you [INAUDIBLE]
information when come back.
And basically,
what I want to say
is that this is
extremely complicated.
But fortunately for you,
Natalie on the Dart team
actually implemented this.
So it has a stack trace package
that is doing that for you.
And this really helps a lot
in asynchronous programming.
And the way this works
is-- so if you go back
to the original program
that I had before.
So this is nothing changed.
The file just shifted
a little bit down.
The only thing you need to do
to have an asynchronous stack
trace is, you import
the stack trace package.
And you call Chain.capture
on the function
call where you want to get
the asynchronous stack trace.
And what happens in
the background is,
now it will do exactly what
I said before in the zones.
It will register as
a zone description,
intercept, all these
kind of things.
And if look at the stack trace
now, it's not much better.
But that's just-- if
you have sharp eyes,
you will actually see that
down there, here, somewhere,
there is a foo,
bar, and the gee,
which is the one that we want.
So we're not done yet.
But it's close.
So what you need to do now
is just have an onError,
take the chain, and get
the terse version of it.
It's already in the
stack trace package.
It's already there.
We just need to use it.
And if we do with that,
then we get what we want.
So I have pulled the
things that I care about.
So that's not part of
the stack trace package.
But we now have a main.
We have the gee.
We have the bar.
We have the foo.
We see that there are
asynchronous gaps to get there.
We really have an idea of how
did we actually get there.
And this is what we want.
This is what we
need for debugging.
And so what I recommend is-- if
you have asynchronous programs
and you want to debug them, try
to use the stack trace package
and see if that
doesn't help you.
So with that, I'm going
to go to the summary.
So really, what I
want you to take away
from this talk is that
from the beginning on,
we had Dart designed sign
for asynchronous programming.
So there are a lot of
primitives and classes
that have good semantics
that work nicely in Dart.
And with Async/Await,
since 9.1, we also
have the nice syntax
that goes with it.
So not only do we have great
classes and [INAUDIBLE].
We also have the syntax
to go with it not.
And then, if you need
to debug, I strongly
recommend to use the stack trace
package to help you figure out
what's going on.
Before I finish, I have
to give some credits.
Really not much in
this talk is new.
Almost everything
has been done before.
Futures are actually
as old as 1976.
At that time, they were
called promises, futures,
or eventuals.
So they have existed
in this world.
They have existed
for a long time.
And there are lots and lots
of JavaScript packages out.
So again, this has
become popular recently.
It's actually to
a point where they
have a standard of how
do you need to interact,
so that you can use
different promise packages,
so that they can
interact with each other.
So there's a standard
now specification
of how your promise
package needs to behave.
So there's a lot of future
and promise going on.
The streams are
something we were heavily
inspired by the Reactive
Extensions in Rx.
So that too comes
from somewhere else.
And the Async/Await has been
made popular by the .NET
frameworking in version 4.5.
And with that, I'm done.
Thank you for listening.
And I do think I do have a
few minutes of questions.
SPEAKER 2: He does.
If folks want to ask
questions, I can repeat them.
And I do want to say too, along
with the debugging question--
so the unit test package
and soon the test
package, all those things run
using this stack trace thing.
So actually, you'll notice
in your testing situation,
your stack traces should
already look good,
because we took care of it in
our testing packages for you.
So again, if you see
Natalie, buy her a whiskey.
She likes whiskey.
Any questions?
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: So a wait for
is basically a syntax that
are more streamed [INAUDIBLE].
So it also returns a
stream subscription.
How do we cancel a subscription?
SPEAKER 2: OK, so
how does a wait
for work with canceling
subscriptions?
FLORIAN LOITSCH: So a
wait for automatically
cancels the subscription
if you leave the loop.
So there's a try catch basically
around it, a try finally,
that makes sure
that if you leave
the loop in a
non-standard way, we
will cancel the subscription.
SPEAKER 2: So people can use
break or throw an exception,
and all that works.
FLORIAN LOITSCH: Yes.
SPEAKER 2: Way in the back.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
FLORIAN LOITSCH: Is
there a performance cost
in the stack trace package?
Can you use it in
production code?
There is a performance cost.
It's basically intercepting
your asynchronous calls.
Depending on how
often that happens
or when you use
asynchronous calls,
it might not matter that much,
because you're asynchronous
anyway.
So you're waiting for something.
But there is an overhead.
SPEAKER 3: I can
add some detail too.
So we use the stack
trace package in pub.
And the way we use it-- because
it's something that you're
dynamically enabling.
When you're running
pub normally,
we just disable collecting
the stack chains,
so that we don't
take a perf hit.
And then if you run
pub in verbose mode,
then we can just
dynamically turn it on.
So you can just
give the end user
the ability to control
that perf cost if you want.
AUDIENCE: What's great is,
there's that one entry point,
right.
So if I don't wrap that top
level closure or that method
with Chain.capture, if you
don't do that, you pay no cost.
And so for instance,
in the test package,
we do that wrapping, but normal
production code, generally not.
FLORIAN LOITSCH:
I also want it add
that, obviously, since you
capture the stack traces,
you collect things.
So you cannot really run
it in production forever.
It will blow up.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
FLORIAN KITSCH: Does it work
for [INAUDIBLE] JavaScript?
I think there's
one outstanding--
SPEAKER 3: That's
a Natalie question.
And I don't know if
Natalie's in here.
SPEAKER 2: We'll find
Natalie. and she'll
be able to answer for you.
FLORIAN LOITSCH: If not,
we should look at it.
AUDIENCE: 30 seconds-- and
of course, if you haven't
looked already, there's actually
been a number of refactorings.
You can look at the pub source
code-- uses Async/Await a lot.
We've done C other refactoring.
SPEAKER 3: A little.
SPEAKER 2: Or a lot.
We're the first
customers, because they
did a lot of I/O. So if you're
looking for examples talk
to me.
And there's a few of us.
We can shoot you some code.
The before and after
is just mind blowing.
It's a really fun.
And it makes the code
a lot more readable.
So definitely take a look at it.
And think you, Florian.
FLORIAN LOITSCH: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]